let's uh try and
uh slow down
yeah with um with a five minute game
nice little username there and fisher
firuzia
the third best and the
136th best player of all time
um
okay um anyway
a little change up from from the
the rat and
i'll go for one of my other
vantablet's favorites which is the
scandinavian with
queen disneyx
now that the pawn uh the response on c4
then
a6 looks pretty juicy in that i'll i'll
win the tempo
by attacking the bishop later on
and that i should shall do
immediately
so i feel like in a lot of lines here
you would go ace
uh you would go a6 b5 even without
getting a tempo so it feels pretty
comfortable for black
and as a matter of fact with uh
if i'm allowed to go c5 and develop
normally
i will probably be a little bit better
um
with better central control and somewhat
more active pieces
so i think 94 is very correct just
trying to
um trying to simplify the game a bit
so uh with with queen c7
um kind of declining the um
the exchange of the of the bishops
which would have occurred after um
94 bishop b4 and i'm thinking that
my bishop on d7 is going to be better
better than his on on d3 since it has a
long diagonal to work on
i was not really worried there about a
possible
um possible
um
[Music]
knight have sex nyx f6 because i would
go gf6 and
i would have possibilities of going
knight d3 later and also root g8
exploiting that
open file now however it seems that he
he is sort of provoking me a little bit
too much here to play actively
i'll i'll yeah i'll happily happily um
um i'll happily be provoked in this
particular case
we don't have an interesting line here
jp if he goes bishop h4 which i believe
is
it's only a real move
that protects f2
and doesn't make bishop takes f3 winning
thread
then i'll take on f3 maybe
um and it was just a very interesting
line there taken f3
queen of three queen xh2 pf1
queen xh4 queen takes 8 a8
check king f6 queen b7 check king f6
queen f3 check and then king g5 and
there are no more checks
oh there's queen f7 there probably it's
no good
i was just thinking in that case maybe
if i could there
take an f2 later on have a couple upon
the
exchange i could have a good position
uh the problem with yeah g3 is that it
doesn't
prevent my main threat which is the
takeoff too
and um i'll i'm attacking the
the queen attacking the bishop on d3
which will fall would check once the
queen moves
discovered check and my opponent resigns
um yeah just uh
a little bit careless there along knight
g4 and
so on so that it
meant that
[Music]
it was so very difficult